Det tar väl 10 minuter innan nästa sådant grej kommer.
Och då var det någon fredag 5, och då var det såhär, är man på måndag sig upp mig, för då blir det ytterligare en grej som var för långt ifrån verksamheten som man skulle ta hand om.
Make Sweden Stronger Men är det så, nu gick vi in, du ska få berätta lite om dig själv, men jag bara hoppar in här lite.
Ja, nu kanske jag får skit för detta, men jag säger det.
Jag håller med.
Men, vad brinner ni mest för?
Idag välkomnar vi Kimmo Björnson till podden, och han har ett sådant där jobb som är lite svårt att beskriva.
Han är någon sorts entreprenör, investerare, sitter i styrelser.
Och, ja, hur beskriver du själv?
Vad du sysslar med, och välkommen till podden.
Ja, tack så mycket.
Det har varierat lite de sista åren, när jag inte varit aktiv i ett specifikt bolag, men i blandning har vi investerare, rådgivare, styrelseledamot, konsult.
Vad säger du till din mamma, om du ska beskriva?
Ja, det säger jag att jag jobbar med, det är ett bolag som jag har jobbat med mest de sista två åren, det är Wacacoo.
Ibland kan man förenkta det och säga att jag jobbar med fashion för damer.
Så det är verkligen beroende på vem som frågar.
När du är med polarna och drar en bash, vad är du då för någonting?
Ja, vad är jag då?
För detta entreprenör då?
Alltså istället, ja men då är det så att du är ju ingenting du tycker om då.
Och det är inte heller sant.
Om man inte känner till dig som person, skulle du kunna ge oss en liten snabb bakgrund så att man förstår vem du är?
Det är ju en kombination av datorer och entreprenör.
Det är verkligen de två sakerna.
IT heter det inte ens från början.
Man är äldre med entreprenörer och IT.
Det är ju grunden.
Så jag har aldrig haft en vanlig chef på det sättet utan det började ju direkt.
Har du aldrig haft ett riktigt jobb så att säga?
Nej, väldigt förenklat så har jag absolut inte haft ett riktigt jobb.
Det första bolaget blev under att vi avbröt universitetsutbildning och så blev det ett bolag istället.
Och innan det så självklart sommarjobb och lite den varianten, men det skulle ingen hävda i ett riktigt jobb då.
Då hade ni kört tre år på samma ställe och plött på?
Nej, inte utan att äga någonting så aldrig.
Kan du inte ge oss en liten sammanfattning över de här?
Vilka bolag är du mest stolt över?
Vilka står med i biografin sen så att säga?
Det första större eller riktiga bolaget var Dadri, vad man då kallar webbyrå, som startade någon precis samtidigt som dotcom sprack, eller strax innan, december 1999, januari 2000.
Det blev i slutan en väldigt prisbelönt reklambyrå i Sverige.
Sen var inte jag så stor del av det för vi delade på det bolaget i två och ett halv tre år.
Jag var med ändå så att ni satt i grunden var det var vi startade.
Det är många som fortfarande känner till det bolaget och varumärket.
Nu finns det inte det sen länge men det var verkligen en kul, stor grej.
Sen var det IT-consulting efter det.
Sen så kokade ihop en lite speciell story i sig, lite annorlunda, väldigt litet bolag.
Sedan är det Map.se såklart som man tyckte var länge men i slutändan när man ser tillbaka inte var så fasligt många år.
Så det är väl Daddy och Map.se som är de två större grejerna.
Men du fastnade ändå vid koka ihop här.
Vad var det som var så roligt med det?
Det var ju speciellt på det sättet att vi inte hade...
Vi hade kunder sedan som var annonsörer och liknande men just att det var ett projekt och dra igång något in från scratch.
Det var en annonsfinansierad recept community.
Var det innan Arla-kök och Ica-recepten?
Ja men det var väl liksom i den tids eran.
Det var Tasteline fanns och nu är det inte Tasteline så det är jättestort varumärke bland folk längre.
Efter att sociala medier blev större så har det väl försvunnit lite.
Nu får folk inspiration från så många håll.
Då var det mest Google.
Hur kommer jag ut på internet?
Jag börjar med Google och då blir det antingen organiskt eller betalda annonser.
Var det inte det så kanske det var tv eller reklam som du säger Arla.
Köket.se var i tv4, så blev det då.
Nu har jag nästan glömt frågan men...
Varför koka ihop var intressant.
Ja men det var ju lite speciellt också att det var användargenererat innehåll.
Det ordet, och det här var 2007, så det var inte så vanligt, det ordet använde sig inte riktigt då.
Så då tänkte man att använda genererat, då tänkte man nog mer att det var Facebook för receptintresserade.
Så beskrev man det då istället.
Men det var annorlunda mot andra projekt på det sättet, att man lärde sig saker från grunden, helt utan investerare eller andra influenser, utan man fick lära sig SEO och AdWords och AdSense som har bytt namn, alla de sakerna.
Men vi använde Amazon Web Services, fast då fanns det typ två tjänster, och nu kanske har vi 400 eller nånting.
Så att man fick från grunden bygga upp nånting som funkar.
Driva trafik via PR, köptrafik och organisk trafik.
Det var inte uppenbart att det skulle bli ett företag så, utan det var lite mer hobbyprojektaktigt.
Så att koka ihop i sig fanns det ju innan det fanns ett bolag.
För om man tar in pengar finns det ingen anledning att göra ett bolag innan man har.
Hur stort blev det till slut och varför la ni ner det?
Det finns faktiskt fortfarande kvar.
Vår första säljare är den som driver det.
Så det finns kvar, men tillväxten är väl stagnerad.
Men vi drev upp det till att vi omsatte 5-7 miljoner.
Däremot har man inte så mycket kostnader om man vill.
Men vi hade ju, jag kommer inte exakt, men kanske 200 000 besökare i veckan.
Det blev en hel del trafik.
Vi skickade otroliga mängder mejl.
Alltså vi skickade miljoner mejl i månaden.
Vilket inte hade varit okej på så många sätt nu.
Det var liksom opt in, vad är det?
Och GDPR fanns inte heller.
Så vi hittade sätt att skapa trafik och nå folk.
Ja, man lärde sig mycket konstiga saker.
Har du någon sorts, besides stort matintresse här eller är det...
Först var det koka ihop och sen blev det mat.se.
Vad är kopplingen däremellan?
Det är lite intressant.
Eller, koka ihop och mat.se är både mat men det var två helt olika anledningar.
Så koka ihop var min kollega Mikael.
Han, så ser jag minst i alla fall, ibland stämmer inte historien med vad man minns, men han hittade en domens som heter kokboken.se och bara namnet var ju såhär, där borde man ju ha recept.
Och vi har inga recept, men om man bara låter folk lägga upp recept, det borde ju, varför ska det inte vara det där?
Och som jag minns det så frågade jag han om vi, eller han fick köpa den, och de ville ha 25 000, tror jag, och det är möjligt, man hade tyckt var rimligt nu, men det är både inflation och att de är nog billigare då, är det såhär, helt vansinnigt, tyckte vi.
Det kan man ju lägga de pengarna på något annat.
Så då spånade jag, men det var ju en kul idé, varför skulle man inte bara kunna göra konten, lägga upp recept på en sajt, det är inte så krångligt, om man har jobbat som utvecklare i hela sitt liv.
Så då hittade vi bara en annan domän.
Jag kommer faktiskt inte ihåg vem som kom på namnet.
Så att det var, vi tänkte göra kodboken.se men domänen var upptagen så det blev en annan namn.
Och så varför inte göra den grejen?
Okej, det var bara en random tanke liksom.
Och hur drog mat.se ihop?
För det är väl det som dom som lyssnar kanske känner bäst igen.
Det blev väl uppköpt sen av mathem.se?
Ja, Vaxfood, mathem efteråt.
Varför det kom till överhuvudtaget och innan hette ens mat.se var idén skulle jag säga kommer primärt ifrån mat.se för detta vd Mons som hade varit vd utanför London på ett företag som gör tacos.
Och i England som är matpanettet mycket längre fram, det låg ett par år före Sverige i fas, liksom i hur stor marknadsandel han hade.
Och Okado heter ett stort företag i England som har, som är framgångsrikt, de sätter väldigt mycket pengar.
Och Mons var samtidigt våran motpart på Santa Maria när vi jobbade som IT-konsulter redan 2001.
Och vi tog över och gjorde om system som styrde bland maskinerna som blandar kryddor och som paketerar kryddor.
Och ja, vi gjorde fabrikssystem, eller gränssnitt till fabrikssystemen så att de som stod och hällde i peppar och ingredienserna stod och stämde av vågen och knappar vidare i receptliknande, våra system.
Och då hade han och några kollegor, eller, förkantade honom idén om att mat på nätet kan man göra bättre i Sverige, efter att ha sett det i England.
Då ringde han oss som han då, vi var då hans före detta konsulter på Santa Maria kan man säga.
Och det kom fram till att om man vill sälja mat på nätet, behöver man ju ett kunna någonting in i ett system, och sen är det ju bra om man kan något en hel del om internet också, annars så faller ju det lite.
Och då frågade han egentligen oss om vi hade såhär, vilka skulle ni prata med?
Och vi tyckte att det kan vi själva göra.
Just då hade vi inga annat företag eller aktiviteter igång än, just Koka ihop, och det ägde vi själva, och det kunde vi kontrollera som vi själva ville.
Plötsligt Koka ihop kunde man ju se som en tillgång från mat.se då, att här har vi några hundratusen varje vecka som letar recept.
I slutan kommer de ju att handla mat också.
Så vi spånar fram en grundargrupp till mat.se tillsammans, vilka som var med och startade mat.se.
Så det är en kombination av att vi hade Koka ihop och att erfarenheten från mat online i England.
Det låter som att ni var ganska många i den grundargruppen.
Ja vi var, i slutan var vi fem.
En liten stund var fem och vi var sex i diskussionen men det ska ju stämma för folk.
Ett att man ska ha ungefär samma idé om vad man ska göra.
Det var nog mest det, hur borde vi göra det här och att man liksom är hyfsat synkad.
Det är bra att tycka lite olika saker men man kan ju inte tycka helt olika omför en mycket saker för då kommer man inte framåt heller när inte något ens finns än.
Än så behöver vi vara lite synkad i åsikterna ändå.
Så när vi har fem.
Hur gör man där i uppstarten när ni tänker att nu ska vi sälja mat på nätet?
Vem är det liksom som tillhandahåller maten i det läget?
Man hade ju aldrig fått för sig att man skulle klara av det om man inte hade haft någon som kommer från branschen och då var ju Måns ifrån jobbat med Santa Maria väldigt länge.
Så det var liksom ett, någon som kan någonting om branschen och sen så blev det liksom två stora punkterna är ju då som du säger var kommer maten ifrån och i Sverige på den tiden så var det okej, men vi har aldrig gjort det här innan vi behöver en grossist.
Och då kan man väl säga att det fanns fyra då, ICA, Coop, Dagab och Bergendals.
ICA säljer bara till ICA, Coop säljer bara till Coop.
Så då finns det bara två kvar då.
Och då kommer jag inte ihåg varför vi, om vi pratar med båda eller inte, jag minns inte, men vi kommer överens med Bergendals som att de skulle kunna leverera mat.
Dock inte all, men man har i normala fall en huvudgrossist.
Och sen så är det andra punkten kapital.
För vissa affärsidéer går att starta och det är jättebra att starta utan pengar.
Men att sälja mat på nätet är praktiskt omöjligt att göra utan kapital.
Om du har affärsidéen att det är veckohandlingen eller att du vill bli den stora kanalen av mat hem till hushåll, då går det inte att göra utan kapital.
Eller jo, det går det utan kapital om man då på den tiden, som även så som mathem startar, som många inte vet, att man plockar in butik.
Du hade ju kunnat gå till en lagom stor rika, vi gör ett samarbete, vi plockar maten i butik, och ser, och så sköpar vi ut den till kunderna.
Det låter väl bra.
Det hade du faktiskt kunnat göra utan kapital.
Alla hade bara att skaffa en kund.
Har du en kund, det kan du ju ha.
Plocka ihop maten till den kunden.
Men våran hypotes var att det kommer aldrig...
Hela grejen var att vi kan göra den här tjänsten att kunderna får betala lagom mycket för maten.
Att du kan få ett bra flöd av mat hem till folk till ett rimligt pris.
Och då kan du få bra volym på det.
Och gör du det på ett kostnadseffektivt sätt så kommer det vara lönsamt i slutändan.
Då är det så här, du kan aldrig göra det igen när du plockar in butik, eftersom butik är gjord för att du ska gå igenom hela butiken.
Så vår hypotes var att vi vill inte plocka i butik alls.
Från ens från början.
Men absolut, det hade man kunnat göra.
Och så steg två, vill du ersätta butiken med ett lager eller liknande.
Jävlar, då hade du ändå gissningsvis varit tvungen att ha pengar då istället.
Så vi ville hoppa över första steget, vi ska aldrig plocka i butik.
Ni drog ett stort plocklager där direkt.
Jag bara tänkte, det måste väl ändå vara lite halvproblematiskt.
Man måste tänka, vilka inköp ska man göra?
Man trodde det, det kändes som att det borde vara ett jätteproblem.
Och man funderar mycket hur vi ska bygga upp systemet för det.
En skillnad mot många andra som har nån sådan här idé var väl att vi kom från it-sidan och alltid gjort mycket system.
Så att vår grundinställning är ju plan A, vi gör systemen själva.
Plan B är att vi får köpa någonting.
Det kan ju bli bra eller dåligt, men i det fallet så är det att det blir väldigt bra och viktigt att ha gjort sin egen system.
Men många andra, om man kommer in med en annan bakgrund, så hade man ju liksom steg ett, vi brukar köpa något vettigt system för det.
Och i en värsta fall, vi behöver utveckla det.
Vi gör helt tvärtom, i värsta fall måste vi köpa någonting.
Men vad vi skulle köpa då, då funderar man ju hur man ska bygga upp den logiken och i slutändan så har du ett flöde av dagligvaror och så får du leveranser ganska ofta.
Och då får du, om du köper exempelvis svartpuppar, så kanske det säljs i 24-pack till retail-ledet.
Och inom avfallet blir det då, ja mer än så kanske vi inte behöver nu.
Så i slutändan blir det egentligen rätt enkelt.
När vi tog in nya leveranser efteråt, du tar en av varje och sen så väldigt snabbt så ser du ungefär hur mycket folk handlar.
Och vipp så vet du hur mycket du ska köpa.
Så det var istället ett icke-problem.
Men jag har lite olika frågor där.
Hur mycket pengar behövde ni få in i start?
Ögonblicket och vem var det som gick in med de pengarna?
Och sen kanske också hur stor, hur fick ni in den första kritiska massan?
Och hur stor behövde den vara?
Nu blir det väldigt många frågor men kanske första, hur fick ni in första investeringarna?
Ja, som ofta när man inte har varit såhär, det är det första bolaget, jag var en bland vi som tog in pengar.
Och det är ju som nästan allt, det känns vanligare nu att folk tar in pengar än vad det var då, jag antar att det är sant, men det var ju helt enkelt kontakter och att vår VDs kusiner var ätlingar till de som startade Santa Maria, som då hade sålt det till Gavia till viss del.
Så att det fanns, det var vår första investerare.
Beroende på hur man ser det så, det är ju aldrig så, ofta är det ju inte så enkelt som man tror, att då har man se så många miljoner till den här och den här värderingen, utan ofta är det ju lite mer komplicerade avtal, så att man kan väl säga att det var någonstans mellan 30 och 60 miljoner i dag.
Så det är ju mycket pengar, samtidigt som nu för tiden så ses det ju ibland som lite pengar.
Ja det är lite lätt att bli blinda av summor, om man tänker på typ 60 miljoner så, det kan man ju leva ett rätt gott liv på, utan att arbeta.
Men när man läser så...
Alla miljoner är ju mycket pengar, och ibland så låter det som jättelite pengar om man har tagit in 5 miljoner, medan det egentligen är mycket, för det kräver ju någon sorts ganska hög värdering, för att det ska vara rimligt att bara ta in några miljoner, utan att bolaget försvinner.
Så att det är helt sant.
Hur började ni sen för att få in lite kunder?
Vi började i Göteborg, så då blir det mycket samla intresse bland vänner och familj, för att bygga upp vad som skulle ses som ett test först möjligen.
Men just när man har färskvaror så blir det lite sådär, vänta, vänta, vänta och vänta, och sen bara måste det vara fullt ös från dag ett.
Det handlar ju bara om hur mycket mjölk det behöver hälla ut, för det kommer ju få svin i färskvaror med låg volym.
Det var ju att försöka gissa hur mycket reklam behöver vi göra för att få någon sorts grundvolym.
Det är ganska svårt, återigen i långt ett snöre grej, en ganska mycket lokalt reklam.
Nu kommer jag inte ihåg om vi körde spårvagnar precis när vi lanserade, men annars så var det ju spårvagnar, bussar och mycket sådant lokalt reklam.
Det som är både bra och dåligt med dagligvaru, jag tycker det mest bra är att det går inte att köpa för hårt med performance marketing, för folk söker inte på bacon om de ska hänga veckohandlingen.
Mat online kan du köpa på Google, men det blir ett par tusen lappar i månaden kanske.
Det går inte att köpa sökord på det sättet, utan all marknadsföring blir mer och mindre varumärkningsbyggande.
Den kan ju vara lite åt att få, hur varumärkningsbyggande och hur mycket det är action marketing med andra sikt äldre uttryck.
Det kan variera, nu har vi rabatter och liknande, men i stort sett all blir någon sorts varumärkningsbyggande för då behöver vi få folk att känna till dig och tänka på dig och ta beslutet själv.
Du fångar dem inte på i sin telefon eller webbläsaren när de tänkte göra veckohandlingen.
Så det är på det sättet positivt att all marknadsföring blir långsiktig.
Till skillnad från om du har väldigt mycket e-handel nu för tiden, så är väldigt mycket marknadsföring kortsiktig.
Det är viktigt att göra det väldigt dyrt i början men du får iallafall kvar effekten lite.
Så det var mycket marknadsföring helt enkelt och så tror jag att första dagen, ett gäng kunde visst du väl för det var bara alla man känner.
Det där snälla handlade dag ett så vi har någon sorts volym första dagen.
Plus att dagligvaror och vår hypotes var ju att du du kommer vilja ha det dagen efter.
Så att vi släppte mer eller mindre på någon dag och att första leveransen som jag minns det var dagen efter mer eller mindre.
Så en vecka innan vi öppnade hade vi egentligen ingen aning om vad vi kunde få.
För det är verkligen dagen innan som det händer.
Jag föme det var runt 30-40 åren första dagen.
Det var ju kaos.
Det är inte mycket men om man har gjort ett helt nytt lager, helt nytt allting helt från scratch.
Dessutom relativt otestat för vi hade ingen...
Det var ju ett tajt schema.
Men runt 30 första dagen och sen gick det uppåt.
Du hade någon fråga där om volym eller...
När började ni komma upp i volymer så att ni kunde driva affären?
Eller att ni började få in kunder på en nivå så att ni kunde planera inköpen, kanske man ska säga.
När kom ni dit?
Det gick nog egentligen rätt fort.
Eller det var ju nästan direkt egentligen.
För vi hade ju ingen aning om säsongsvariationerna.
Och då menar jag både årsvis och veckovis.
Men direkt efter ett par veckor så fattar man ju variationen måndag till fredag.
För att så som folk handlar mat i butiken, så har ju ICA en viss veckovariation.
Medan mat på nätet har en annan veckovariation, där måndag och fredag är störst och onsdag minst.
Det är liksom en hängmatta.
Det hade vi ingen aning om, bevisst och ingenting.
För det fanns ju ingen som gjorde det här i stor skala i Sverige.
Men det mönstret var ju direkt och sakta men säkert volymen uppåt.
Sen så är det ju en peak i januari och augusti när man får nya kunder, just hur dagligt var det på nätet.
Så här, tillbaka efter semestern eller nyårslöfte, jag vet inte.
Och sen kan det kännas att det går lite trögare på våren och hösten då, så vi kanske inte visste när vi lanserade under sommaren eller slutet på sommaren, August och september, så visste vi egentligen inte om det var bra eller dåligt att vi sålde lika mycket som månaden innan, för vi kände inte till årssäsongsvariationerna än.
Men vi hade ju den volymen vi hade i alla fall, så då tog vi bara jobba på.
Man kan väl säga att efter ett år hade man en indikation på tillväxt.
För efter, om vi startar i juni eller juli, jag har kommit ihåg, när man är till och med hela vägen fram i april, så tror man att då visste vi egentligen inte vad vår tillväxt var.
För vi visste inte riktigt hur mycket det skulle bli efter sommaren.
Man hade väl någon sorts gissning.
Men sen spelade det inte det så stor roll som du tänkte börja inköpa på planering och så.
Vi omsatte hela lageret på sju dagar.
Man planerar inte.
Det hade vi en grossist i slutan av hälften av flödet.
Jag kommer inte ihåg hur ofta men jag har för mig att ungefär tre dagar i veckan så var det en dubbelångt radare med pallar.
Så man planerar inte inköp på det sättet.
Man funderar strategiskt vilka nya leverantörer du vill ha eller vilka du vill ta bort.
Sedan du väl har den så är det mer kampanjansvariga och leverantörskategoriansvariga som jobbar med leverantörerna för att sätta roliga kampanjer mot kunderna eller som matchar med deras mål om nya produkter eller liknande.
Inte så mycket man ska ha i lag.
Hur gick resan därför?
Mat på nätet har ju generellt sett nu haft några tunga år, men liksom växten är lignärt, gick det bra, tjänar ni pengar, du vet.
Det var aldrig lönsamt.
Sedan så vi startade i Göteborg då, Eget Lager.
Sedan det var sommaren 2012.
2014 så öppnade vi Eget Lager i Stockholm och sedan så minns jag inte när vi öppnade Eget Lager i Malmö, men något år senare.
Så vi öppnade nya lager innan det första laget var lönsamt.
Mat på nätet, för mig, är ganska nyckeltalsberoende, det är fel ord men det är väldigt viktigt med nyckeltal när man driver mat på nätet business, för det är ganska låg marginal på mat.
Men så här, 28-29% kan det vara, det är ju olika butiker och så här, men man kan ha 30% mat till exempel.
Och då blir det väldigt viktigt exakt hur dyrt laget är att hantera, exakt hur dyrt det är att köra ut varorna.
Det blir en eget varumärke business i e-handel nu för tiden, om man har 70-78% bruttomaginal.
Nyckeltalen är inte riktigt lika viktig för flödet.
Flödet är lönsamt.
Mat på nätet, så du behöver säkerställa att du kan ha ett lönsamt flöde, för annars spelar det inte någon roll för oljmen över huvud taget.
Vi kom till bra nyckeltal i Göteborg, där vi tjänar, eller vi förlorar mindre och mindre pengar ju mer kunder vi hade.
Så varje nyår var det lönsamt, och på minst rätt så var vi även lönsamma eftermarknadsföringskostnader i Göteborg.
Men sedan har vi ett helt huvudkontor som vi ska täcka också.
Dock inte så stort.
Men i Stockholm och Malmö så kom vi inte till den nivån än.
Så vi trodde ju att det var mer bråttom än vad det var.
Både vi och Maten trodde nog att det var ganska bråttom.
Maten var först i Stockholm, vi var inte först i Göteborg men vi blev väldigt snabbt störst.
Så vi var ett typ först och nån och en slags volym i Göteborg.
Och då var väl vår hypotes som i dag kan vara störst i Göteborg och i Malmö.
Då kan vi på något sätt hävda oss i Sverige.
Om de är störst i Stockholm, vi försöker inte vara störst i Stockholm utan låter det ta sin tid.
Så då ungefär samtidigt så öppnade både Maten och Malmö.
Men på något sätt var det olika typer av kunder i de tre storslödsregionerna.
Det var inte samma snittkasse och inte samma frekvens.
Det varierade lite.
Vi hade liknande men vi hoppades.
Det var bäst nyckeltal i ett år i snittorder och liknande.
Så det blev lite mer kostsamt än vad vi hoppades i både Stockholm och Malmö.
Och totalen blir då rätt så kostsam såklart.
Det var varierande.
Varierande stora förluster.
Jag förstår exitresan där, sen hur gick den till?
2014 så gjorde vi en kapitalanskaffning där vi ställde ett olika alternativ mot varandra.
Det slutade med att vi listade bolaget på First North som en oreglerad marknad, fast ändå Nasdaq som äger.
Nu heter det något annat.
Definitionen av, det ligger numera under finansinspektionen men det gick ju fortfarande att handla på Avanza och på Bankeris här.
Men det är inte lika höga krav som var på huvudmarknaden.
Så det var lite steg 1 mot exit möjligen.
Men då och efter det så gjorde vi ett antal mindre kapitalanskaffningar medan vi var börsnoterade.
Sen blev vi ju, alltså dagligvarubranschen, det är inte så många aktörer.
Så det är klart att vi hade pratat med Axfood tidigare i helt andra ärenden.
Och de stora kedjorna i Sverige, alla kollar på hur kommer internet att utveckla sig.
Ica och Coop har ett annat typ av ägande, Ica med alla butiker.
De har haft svårt att köpa ett varumärke.
Coop är ju en förening och driver sitt på något sätt, medan Axfood har ändå några olika varumärken och funderar på hur ska vi bli bra på dagligvaror online.
Om man tittar internationellt, så ser man att de flesta som har lyckats är sådana som inte har varit dagligvaruhandlare.
Utan att det är någon annan entreprenör som lyckas med det.
Det var en hypotes de drev kan man säga, och kontaktade oss formellt via styrelse och liknande för att det ska göras på rätt sätt om en är noterad och lav bud helt enkelt.
Dock så vi hade absolut inte tänkt att sälja det då, men vi hade ju ett antal investerare och sen ett par tusen ägare totalt sett eftersom vi var noterade.
Och tyvis behöver man ju känna någon sorts ansvar för alla ägare.
Men de första nivåerna tackade vi nej till som storägare.
Och sen återkom de med högre och högre bud och till slut så var det väl så högt att vi var oansvarigt och tackade nej liksom.
Ungefär 100% över börskursen.
Och en av vad som hade påverkat var att om vi hade varit, det har gått väldigt mycket upp och ner hur man värderar e-handelsbolag.
Och det här var hösten 2016.
Då var inte det coolt att vara e-handlare för börsen.
Vi var värderade till, jag tror, en bit under 200 miljoner var vi väl värderade till.
Och hade gjort en kapitalanskaffning på 100 miljoner på hösten.
Det är ju en seriell utspädningar.
Hade vi varit värderade mycket högre, hade det enklare att ta in pengar, då hade vi kanske varit för dyra att de inte ens varit intresserade av att köpa oss istället.
Men det hängde ihop att vi tyckte att vi var lågt värderade, men bevisligen tyckte också att vi var för lågt värderade när de accepterade ett bud som var 100% över.
Men om världen gjorde att det som hände hände, att vi var värderade på det sättet och att vi behövde se så mycket pengar och att man var tvungen att ta hänsyn till andra.
Sen går det ganska fort, om det är noterad så blir det mer.
Det är inte samma som att sälja ett litet bolag och hur länge blir det uppblåst och sådana saker, utan det behöver vi hantera alla ägare på samma sätt.
Det är ju massa ägare, tusentals ägare som inte ens har någon koppling till bolaget eller liknande, så det blir ju ganska normalt att det blir allt eller inget.
Vem lämnade du bolaget där?
Vissa grunder lämnade det ganska snart.
Jag var kvar lite...
Det här var när Köpdike gick igenom var nog början på 2017.
Jag slutade någon gång 2018, när det var såhär...
Axfood omsatte väl 40 miljarder om jag minns rätt.
Jag behöver inte minnas rätt men ungefär.
Vi omsatte 300-400 miljoner, så vi blev typ 1 procent av Axfood.
Så vi är ju försumbara.
Det var när vi satt med någon sorts presentation eller det skulle vara någon sort fokusgrupp och någonting i koncernen.
Så här, ja men okej, men om vi bara får klart den här grejen så kanske vi kan börja jobba med businessen i det här, ungefär så kändes det.
Och sen när den utredningen, fokusgruppen, var klar så tar det väl 10 minuter innan nästa sån grej kommer.
Och då det var någon fredag för mig och då var det såhär, när man på måndag sa upp mig för då blev det ytterligare en grej som var för långt ifrån verksamheten som man skulle ta hand om.
Så någon, då var två grunder kvar efter mig, någon stannade lite längre.
Det blev varför man slutade eller inte, vad handlade det nog mer om, vad man var i livet och vad som passade eller inte.
Men vi var för små, vi var för irrelevanta för elheten så att det var...
Jag fattar, man går från att göra sin resa på sitt sätt och sen blir man del av någonting, kanske enormt, ens egna resa inte spelar lika stor roll längre, då blir det något helt annat.
Ja, och det kan man ju fråga och fundera på varför de köpte oss om man får känslan av att vi inte var relevanta då.
Men det är ju internpolitik i det bolaget.
Exakt, vad hände sen när du var klar med detta?
Man brukar ju säga att man får en sån Founder Blues, att man blir deppig eller ledsen, nedstämd, man tappar lite syfte eller vad gjorde du?
Nej, däremot två små barn.
Var du deppig på grund av det eller?
Nej, mer att man behöver inte fundera på vad man ska göra.
2013, 2016.
Så att vi hade jobbat sjukt mycket de sista åren där.
Det var lite skönt att landa kanske.
Ja, annars kan det nog vara om man inte har barn till exempel och du plötsligt inte måste jobba och du inte har någon idé vad du ska jobba med.
Så varför behöver du gå upp tidigt i morgonen då liksom?
Exakt.
Men det var inget.
Nu vill jag inte fundera på det.
Och vad hände där sen när du hade landat lite?
Hur gick det till när det började klia lite i fingrarna och du skulle gå in i nästa roll så att säga?
Är man vana att driva i eget?
Det klia nog alltid i fingrarna på något sätt.
Sen så är det lite klurigt det här och det kan det vara fortfarande.
Hur mycket kan man vara investerare?
Och hur mycket skulle det vara att hjälpa folk med styrelsearbete, rådgivning, så här.
Det är lite, det är inte helt lätt att ha massa roller på en gång liksom.
Vilken roll är du mest bekväm i?
Vilken roll är det du trivs i?
Jag är ju nog bättre på att utföra saker än att råd ge egentligen, samtidigt som vissa, det är väldigt svårt att ha den insikten själv tror jag.
Det kan vara saker man säger till folk som har hjälpt dem väldigt mycket fast man själv inte känner till det.
Så man kan ha svårt med självinsikt om det är lyckad rådgivning eller inte.
Det kan vara lätt att anta att man inte har hjälpt någon för att man är van vid att man kanske gör någonting som tar flera hundra timmar.
Sen sitter man och pratar med någon en halvtimme, då tänker man att per definition så kan inte det värt så mycket för det tog inte så lång tid.
Medan det kanske var värt mycket för dem.
Men ibland får man reda på det och ibland inte.
Och skapa saker är väl liksom roligast så.
Jobbar du någonting idag, bygger mjukvara eller är det en sortens operativt jobb?
Ja, det gör jag av en slump.
Jag jobbar ju med, jag är ordförande i Oaxaco som är ett e-handelsbolag.
Och det omsätter ungefär hundra miljoner.
Vilket är, som du vet, egentligen inte alls mycket när man jobbar med e-handel.
För först ska du köpa in varorna och sen så har du flöden som också är såhär, som inte bidrar så mycket till värde.
Så vad har du kvar efter hela flödet?
Det är ju liksom på något sätt den lilla bilkring som man typ egentligen omsätter, för det är bara det man kan anställa människor att relera marknadsföring för.
Räknar man på inköpen, fraktreina och lagen?
Lagen om du driver i lagen, så då ska ni ta hand om det då.
Men det är inget stort bolag och då i och med min erfarenhet av att bygga extremt mycket logistik, operationssystem, innan det var matproresset så jobbade jag med biljettbokningssystem, jobbat med Göteborgs hamn, hanterade tågklarering, eller fabriksystem och den typen.
Så följde det sig att det är lite diverse affärsnära system på AKK som har behövts fixas och då har jag jobbat med det också.
Så jag är den lite udda kombinationen IT-konsult och styrelseordförande samtidigt i OAKA KU.
Så jag är indirekt min egna chef.
Men det funkar väldigt bra när man är en så liten organisation, det spelar egentligen inte tid till den andra rollen då.
Det viktiga är ju att man är en liten grupp som driver det.
Har du också den här sköna...
Jag har några polare i 50-årsåldern som är gamla programmerare.
Nu är de nån sorts senior, så då kanske de mer projektleder och så där.
Men när de...
Vi kan sitta ut och ta en bash och då säger de att jag hade lite tråkigt igår kväll, så då satt jag mig och kordade en stund för skojskuld.
Har du också den där grejen där du bara...
Vad skönt det vore att sätta sin korda en liten stund?
Ja, absolut.
Ja, men hundra procent.
Så är det ju.
Det är så logiskt på något sätt.
Ja, och många som...
Det finns nog olika typer av programmerare möjligen, men programmerare brinner ju mycket mer än vad folk inser för just att skapa saker.
Snarare än folk som inte jobbar med det matematiska tragglandet, utan att det faktiskt är någon sorts kreativt skapande.
Om man hade spånat fram vad man skulle starta för lönsamma företag, så hade man inte kommit fram till att man skulle sälja mat på nätet.
Även om du lyckas så kommer du inte att ha så hög marginal, utan då är det mer att man blir tryggare av att man tror man kan skapa någonting som någon annan inte har lyckats skapa.
Men det där försöker de, fast jag tror att det kan jag eller vi göra bättre och att man då känner någon sorts inspiration och skapar det snarare än att komma fram till vad som är en vettig affärsidé.
Sen så behöver ju det, om det ska bli ett företag av det dessutom så behöver det hänga ihop på något sätt.
Men det blir samma, för att du ska vara lyckad så blir det samma med investerarna.
De tänker ju på samma sätt att i stort sett, eller jag har fått före mig, i stort sett alla investerare har ju någon sorts tank om vad som de kanske vill ska vara bättre i samhället eller i världen så att de även investerare letar kanske inte alltid efter det som är högst avkastning, utan att de kanske vill vara en del av att någonting kommer skapas som de tycker borde skapas.
Och jag tror även att det är det bästa sätt, att det är viktigt att det är större chans att det blir bra, att du klarar av att leva, att du tycker det är roligt längre och att det kommer funka.
Vad är din roll oftast i, för du har ju verkligen ett gäng olika bolag, kan du hitta vad är det du oftast faller in i för synsätt eller trycker på är viktigast här?
Jag ramlar väl ofta in i processer och sådant som väldigt många tycker är otroligt tråkigt.
Hur det borde fungera är en teoretisk, hur det borde vara en process som bara funkar.
Jag jobbar väldigt mycket med ekonomi i matfaktr.se och jag är ju inte ekonom, utan jag kommer ju mer från ett annat håll med matematik.
Jag pluggade matematik och datavetenskap som jag hoppade av för länge sedan.
Och så ser det från flödes-
och process-håll att det här ska inte vara så krångligt.
Om det bara funkar på det här sättet så ska väl det här funka.
Så det är liksom rollen av att se mönster och processer och även förhoppningsvis snabbt se rimligheter, att se samband, att om man ser till folk som pitchar och pitchar idéer och så här, år det och det så ska vi ha CEO såhär många kunder.
Och om man snabbt ser samband, att det har fast i normala fall kostat de CEO så många miljoner och skaffat ungefär så många kunder så ska ni lyckas med det så kommer era kunder att ha kostat sju kronor i snitt att skaffa.
Det kan ju hända här förutom att det händer för en miljonterdel av alla bolag att någonting blir så viralt så att se rymligheter liksom att det här kommer att tal inte kunna hända för det här är taget i luften.
Sen ser mönster och samband och den typen av saker.
Ja men kan vi inte snacka lite om minusresultat?
Vi har ju gjort några resor med minusresultat och för ja men för några år sedan så uppmuntrades det ju till att man skulle gå minus och nu får ju nästan inte ens de bolagen som ska gå minus gå minus.
Hur skadligt är det för marknaden att folks eller investerare värderingar varierar så mycket?
Ja men det är ju väldigt skadligt tycker jag.
Eller jag har sett fall på såhär.
Om du blir mycket med det här tillbaka till den då icke-matematiska delen av det, för att om du har en idé, det lyckas av någon anledning värdera dig till 100 miljoner och ta in 20 miljoner, då har du någon sorts krav på dig att leverera någonting som antagligen ska växa ganska fort och det känns nästan som att du har ett krav på dig att ta på dig kostnader.
För varför skulle du annars ha tatt in 20 miljoner?
Det är ju konstigt då.
Låt säga att du blir 10 anställda och kommer upp i omsätta 5-8 miljoner och går bara några miljoner back till exempel.
Och sen så då 2021-2022 till exempel, så tittar man på den verksamheten och säger att om ett antal år kanske de kan gå någon miljon plus.
Då kanske de kan värda 10-20 miljoner om några år.
Då kanske vi vill värdera det till 7 miljoner nu bara för att vi vill ha en uppsida.
För att de ska kunna snurra runt det så behöver de 15 miljoner nu.
Men så här, nu behöver ni 15 miljoner och värdera det till 7.
Då blir det för stor utspädning och det är mer psykologiskt.
För det hade ju kunnat vara okej, men man vill ju att grundare ska ha med incitament och driva det.
Om du vill ta in 15 miljoner så är det svårt om du inte värderar det till över 45-50 miljoner för du kanske måste göra det igen och liknande.
Så det måste matcha värdering och mycket pengar du tar in.
Och då helt plötsligt så går det...
Ja det blir ett olösbart problem det företaget då för de har ju dragit på sig så många...
De måste ju ha väldigt mycket lägre kostnader för att det liksom helheten ska hänga ihop.
Hur mycket kostnader har vi, vad är vi värderade till, hur mycket pengar behöver vi.
Det måste liksom matcha lite och det är väldigt krångligt om man ändrar värderingar 40-80-90% neråt.
Helt plötsligt får man en olösbar ekvation.
Ja det är kombinerat med även de fallen där man tar in en del lån vilket tyvärr ofta är almi.
Varför tyvärr?
Jo, jag menar för jag tycker att många bolag som går back och har en bit kvar till lönsamhet borde inte ta några lån över huvud taget.
För det är för hög risk.
För om man värderar verksamheten till 10-20 miljoner och man sitter på ett lån på 15 miljoner då är det sunda förnuftet och det som är rimligt hur man värderar det bolaget då är att ni har en verksamhet värd 20 miljoner men sen är det 15 miljoner i skuld.
Det som ligger på balansräkningen som tillgång är egentligen allting ni har utvecklat och det är egentligen det vi värderar bolaget.
Det är det som är bolaget för oss och det tänker vi inte plussa på.
Då blir själva aktiebolaget i sig värt max 5 miljoner eller i många fall minus eller väldigt nära noll.
Det går inte att investera i någonting som inte är värt någonting.
Ni behöver 10 miljoner om vi värderar er till en krona.
Eller om vi värderar er till en miljon, det spelar ingen roll.
Det blir ändå så här, pengarna ni behöver är mångfaldt mycket mer av vad det går att värdera er till och till stor del på grund av att ni har en skuld.
Så när skulden närmar sig verksamheten i värde, eller bara närmar sig hälften av verksamheten, så blir multiplen på vad du behöver ta in så stor att psykologin i att du klarar inte av att behålla något incitament för ägarna, för att utspärringen hade blivit så stor.
Och då blir det så här, då blir det krystade lösningar att man får ge ägande på olika sätt till grundare som alltid, som kan vara gråzonlagligt eller så är det att någon annan blir utstrafad på grund av att det blir bara problem liksom.
Du kan inte ha bok som det enklaste att få lån ifrån är Almin som är statligt.
Så det blir så här, du skapar en så stor risk så att du ser till att bolaget går under när du har trott att förut vara snäll.
Det här kommer ju helt garanterat folk att tycka helt tvärtom mot mig.
Till exempel de som ansvarar på Almin för att låna ut pengar.
Men jag hörde ju att de borde bara gå in med Echo och inte ju aldrig låna ut några pengar.
Dessutom är det ju inte speciellt låga räntor.
Men sen så är det ju ofta utan borgen så då tycker de att det är statligt och snällt för att de inte sätter personerna i skuld.
Men nu syns det ju någon bolag som försvann då.
Ja, jag köper det.
Jag har nog aldrig tänkt på det så.
Alltså visst att lån kan vara negativt men har du sett hur den investerar i synpunkten så?
En ren tillgång som står mot lånet så blir det en annan sak.
Lysa en bil och tänk såhär, okej det skett sig.
Vi gör oss av med tillgången och betalar lånet.
Eller om du belånar ditt lager.
Det är lite mer riskigt men det finns åtminstone...
Det är hyfsat sannolikt att vi kan sälja av de där grejerna och betala lånet.
Men det bästa exempelet är om du köper en maskin som gör någonting.
Då är det väl högst rimligt att låna för att köpa den då.
Den har väl något värde.
Men om du lånar mot i materiella tillgångar eller om du lånar mot inget, ingen rimlig pann.
Jag fattar, man har inget av konkret värde så...
Om man nu är ett bolag och man vet att man kommer gå minus, hur sätter man upp det från start för att det ska bli bra?
Många tror att de här nyckeltalen kommer att bli jättemycket bättre med skala.
Det är väl det jag generellt ser att det blir inte det.
Man kommer ganska snabbt, i många fall upp till skalfördelarna ganska fort.
Man måste se att om vi skalar bolaget, vi säljer mer.
Men med ungefär liknande typ av kostnader och flöden, då blir det lönsamt.
Så om man ser verksamheten eller sin idé och att motivera att det går minus för att man tror att vissa saker kommer hända, då blir det väldigt svårt.
Om man mer ser att det här skulle fungera i högre skala, då känns det mer rimligt.
Om ni skulle sälja tio gånger så mycket av era stor säljare så är det inte så många procent.
Jag gissar lite.
Jag tror ännu inte att det är så kallt i skal.
Sen är ni inte pyttesmå heller.
Så men det är nog inte som natt och dag vad du fick betala när ni omsatte tio miljoner för med åtta miljoner heller.
Folk tror att man kan inte bara hitta på någonting som kommer hända.
Det kan ju låta lite negativt också.
Det är väl inte så man hittar.
Men jag fattar det du säger egentligen är att bara för att du skalar så blir inte alla utgifter mindre procentuellt sett.
Till exempel vissa, om du går från en miljon till tio miljoner så kanske dina inköpspriser blir lägre.
Men det finns ju en gräns när du slår i ett tak och du inte får lägre pris på produkter till exempel.
Framförallt overheadden, det är rent fasta.
Det är där vinsten måste komma.
Men för ganska många e-handelsbolag så kanske inte det är den jobbigaste punkten.
Nej, sen har det rört på sig så otroligt mycket.
Nu har det varit perfekt storm åt alla håll sen 2020 eller 2021 snarare.
Nu vet man ju knappt vad ett vanligt år är längre.
2019 är det senaste året som inte var kaos.
Och i e-handel blir det ju så, är det här gångbart?
Om vi skalar det här och har ungefär liknande kundaskaffningar, hur funkar det då?
Kommer vi tjäna pengar i slutändan?
Men om det förutsätter att man halverar någonting, dessutom så är det lite mer tveksam idé då.
Jag tycker att väldigt många underskattar grundidén och överskattar sin egen påverkan eller någon anställd påverkan.
Det kan också låta syniskt vara en åsikt som inte alla håller med om.
Och att det ofta är en slump.
Vissa klädmärken som har mycket stretch kan ju vara en efterhandskonstruktion.
Att det är toppen för lågare turer.
Att vissa nu har blivit duktigare på att tänka e-commerce först.
Men många tidigare lyckade projekt som funkar på nätet.
Som man ser att det är en perfekt idé att ha på internet.
Det var inte alls det de tänkte på.
Det var inte därför.
Utan att det var en passion eller idé eller så här.
Det är det här vi vill göra liksom.
Grundtanken spelar mer roll än tweaks i slutändan.
Om du har 67% bruttomarginal så kan du jobba väldigt mycket för att förbättra det till 68-69.
Men anledningen är inte att du har övertagit det för din grundläggande affärsidé.
Och då spelar det ingen roll om du byter den ena marknadsföringskonsultern mot en annan.
Det kommer att bli promillen bättre.
Det som grundaren satt det, eller så här, det är superviktigt så sedan det börjar.
Allting är mer trög rörligt än vad man tror.
Det är samma också, men det där löser vi sen.
Det där kostnaden drar vi ner sen.
Eller vi blir lönsamma senare fast du inte vet hur riktigt.
Det kan ju, nu är det svårt att veta hur extremfallet Amazon och liknande tänkte.
Liksom hur deras kalkyler såg ut.
Och sen ser det också dumt ut att ta det lätt att få och dra upp sådana exempel som en på miljarden eller en på miljonen.
Det händer inte alla liksom.
Jag fattar, jag fattar, var realistisk och så ha en lönsam grund i det och så får man bygga utifrån det helt enkelt.
Jag har investerat i bolag som jag kan inte kalla att jag är någon bra investerare för jag har investerat i många bolag som har gått i konkurs.
Men man kan se, ni gör väldigt mycket marknadsföring, ni förlorar mycket pengar, men har ni den här kundens skaffningskostnader, en av de här marginalerna, så behöver det inte bli bättre, då kommer det att funka.
Och i åtminstone något fall så har det stämt.
Och någon annan man ser, det här är en director consumer, och ni har jättehög körn, kunderna försvinner.
Hade ni bara behållit kunderna lite bättre, så hade det här varit bra tillväxt.
Hur slutar det igen, de lyckas aldrig behålla kunderna, så det slutar med konkurs.
Så, om grundmodellen har hög körn, så kan du absolut få den att bli lägre, men du kan inte helt plötsligt få den att bli låg på riktigt, för det kanske inte ingår i din idé.
Den typen av saker som du säljer har inte det.
Då har du ju en trasig affärsidé snarare.
Vi kan ju dra det i egen sak, vi säljer ju gymutrustning, och ofta då är ju första köpet till exempel ganska stort, och där måste ju vi vara lönsamma, för det funkar ju inte så att en kund återkommer varje år och köper ett nytt löpande eller en ny cykel, utan man kanske kommer om två år och köper lite smågrejer, och då måste vi ha en affärsmodell där första köpet är lönsamt.
Ett liknande exempel är att vi fick in väldigt mycket trafik på konstiga sökord på Koka ihop.
Vi var stora på att följa kanträllor.
Och det är billigt att köpa recept, smörgås tårta på Google.
Vi köpte ju trafik också men vi köpte ju på så många konstiga ord så det kostade ju nästan ingenting.
Och då gick vi in lite på vin.
Och för jag hade många annonsörer som var vinimportörer, vilket var väldigt lyckosamt som annonsnisch, men då var det såhär, ja men det är klart vi kan skapa en sektion med dryck på sajten.
Liksom, att man äter, man dricker, det hänger ju upp liksom.
Men bara för någon som var intresserad av att äta av ett recept så kommer de absolut inte att vara intresserade av och just det de är till för att titta på vin från Spanien.
Det är väldigt svårt att utöka, expandera i nya vertikaler som man tycker hänger lite ihop.
Du har skrivit någon gång, testa lite nya vertikaler, det är väldigt sällan så lätt som man tror.
Som idén har varit, vi gör det här och sen så kommer vi utnyttja de kunderna för att sälja lite mer av det här och det här.
Då är det rätt stor chans att det inte kommer hända.
Vi behöver komma, grundidén behöver vara tillräckligt bra.
Sen kan man, de riktigt lyckade, att Bård och Henrik Lånsson lyckades hitta nya vertikaler.
Vi får ju ofta den frågan, ska ni inte ta in kostig skott?
Nej, det känns ungefär samma som ljumutrustning, men det är inte samma sak.
Kostig skott marknadsförs mycket med influencers, det är en helt annan marknadsföring.
Det är mycket mer varumärkesbetonat, det är mycket mer prispressat på ett annat sätt.
Det är en färskvara, snittköpet är tio gånger lägre än vad vi normalt sett har.
Det är en helt annan logistik.
Så det känns samma men det är liksom inte samma.
Vi ska stänga ner där för idag.
Stort, stort tack för att du var med Kimmo och att jag fick sitta och fråga ut dig om din resa.
Tack för att du var med idag.
Ja, tack själv.
Vi har kommit då exakt med kanske 200 000 besökare i veckan.
Det blev en hel del trafik.
Vi skickade otroliga mängder mejl.
Alltså vi skickade miljoner mejl i månaden.